okay so therefore what's this gonna look
like well I'm imagining don't draw
anything just yet I'm imagining
something like Miss right now do you see
how this makes sense of the regions that
we have look at the regions that you've
got see over here I'm supposed to end
down in this corner well the function we
looked at first all it does into this
corner it approaches this acetone but
this guy the one we're looking at right
now it ends in this corner but it's
going down it's dropping away does that
make sense
and of course in the opposite corner you
can see it's going up into that
direction does that make sense okay so
we used calculus right now this next
step is the part which I said you're
like how would you know to do this well
we're going to get to this a bit later
on to work out exactly where it is
because see this line this is 1 minus X
it's got the right gradient but minus X
also has the right gradient and minus X
minus 1 also has the right gradient so
which of these is the oblique asymptote
ok I want us to come back to the
original function I've run out of space
over here so this is the original
function remember I separated this guy
out for the purpose of differentiation
to remember that and that's why I wrote
it with this negative index but if you
write it without the negative index like
so ok I can think about this in terms of
limits again and I have it in a more
useful form than what I had before right
the minute of Y is a limit of this let's
just substitute now remember you told me
this guy here it approaches zero right
as X gets bigger and bigger and bigger
well what about this guy what is it to
this guy the denominator gets bigger it
does exactly the same thing as that it
doesn't do it quite as fast because this
is squared but this also goes to 0 does
it not also goes to 0 so therefore this
is going to go toward this now I could
have tried to put infinity to here but
you don't get something useful out of it
it just blows up it just becomes
infinity ok but what this is telling you
is that what you get left weird like
this
vanishes away it sort of doesn't
contribute anything meaningful as X
approaches very large values right so
all you get left with is this guy this
is your oblique asymptote y equals that
okay so therefore I can now come back to
my original graph at last and I can put
on my oblique asymptotes like so this is
y equals minus X ok now I have enough
information let's have a think about
this how can I go through all the
regions I'm supposed to hit all the
intercepts I'm supposed to and also
match up to all the asymptotes that I
have now I've got all of them ok well
let's have a look at this left-hand side
have a look at this side here okay I'm
gonna have to go up to what this
asymptote right so I guess I'm gonna
start from this intercepted I'm gonna go
up toward the asymptotes like that it
gently curved because doesn't actually
get there right what about down here
what's it gonna do well it's got it's
got another asymptote to go to what
doesn't the vertical one so it's just
going to sort of lead down like that
yeah what about on the other side well
it sort of does the same thing but in in
Reverse right or rotated around in fact
which is not a coincidence if you have a
look up here you've got to go to where
this vertical has to it like that like
so and then down here I've got another
leg asymptote to approach that there's
the graph now this is a strange base
because of this oblique asymptote it's
so straight you're really used to seeing
things like this and the reason why is
because we start with these because it's
easy to find out what their horizontal
asymptotes are okay
but now you know calculus now you know
enough to be a bit suspicious and say
wait it's going towards something else
what is it actually specifically going
toward ok now one last quick question
for these guys here you know how I
showed you some weird versions where you
have like a horizontal asymptote like
this and sometimes it sort of crosses
and then it it goes like that right now
how do I know that's something like the
isn't happening over here how do I know
for instance that up here it doesn't
actually sleep over the ass enjoy it and
then come back down I'll use a different
color because that sounds really weird
like this how do I know it doesn't do
that you've got two ways that you can do
it I'll give you a clue once with
calculus and once without you thought
yeah okay so which function is even that
you're thinking of you're talking
medicine yeah yep that's true
yep okay so you're absolutely right I
can't cross vertical asymptotes okay why
is that by the way think of where we've
got the vertical asymptotes from tell me
why I can't cross it
it's a disk or - do you write because
look you can't you can't put in X equal
zero the whole thing blows up okay but
remember the horizontal and Vikes that
should be oblique asymptotes they only
tell you about the edges of the graph
they say nothing about the inside okay
Kesey like look near here the origin the
oblique asymptote goes right through
there but the graph doesn't care he's
like I I couldn't care less if you were
there it just goes straight up and
ignores it okay so in here you can't
cross if you're like talking in the
symmetry well I can have it on both ends
okay
like in theory I can do that why not why
doesn't it do that hmm we are we
differentiated right we differentiated
over here is there's the derivative okay
if it were to do this weird Wiggly fee
all right this wiggle around this week
around do you see it looks to be like
there would be a stationary point of
some kind right a stationary point see
how it sort of goes up and it turns yeah
well how would I find such an object I'd
do that I would say the first derivative
should be zero right well let's see what
happens I had the first review it's over
there minus one over x squared minus one
equals zero
yeah so let's see what happens I'm
trying to solve for x squared so I guess
I'll add one to both sides uh I guess I
multiply through by x squared now
in the scheme that I'm working in
that's um that makes me sad I can't find
solutions for here on the Cartesian
plane I can't find solutions elsewhere
but I'm not I don't have them I've got
the Cartesian plane right now okay so
this means I have no real solutions no
real solutions so if there's no spot at
which it turns then I don't think I
could really do that okay so these
questions are hard right working this
kind of thing out I will just give you
one more clue which is to say when you
get given the questions like this now
you'll get given them in a form where
you can just divide through you can just
divide through I can make this question
a teeny bit harder and you can't pull
off the trick that I just did I can do
this why does this make things so much
more difficult it's just a harmless
constant
what's the big problem how do I work
this out before what did I do to get
this exact equation I didn't just guess
I actually got that exactly wait what
did I do
I am yeah all right you got
yeah so so this is the key step over
here do you remember it like that's why
I still have it written down here this
is where I got y equals minus X from but
I could only do that because I could
split apart this fraction into two you
see that into here and here and I could
do it relatively easily right you cannot
do it relatively easily here you needed
you tool a tool I'll introduce to you
the topic called polynomials called
polynomial division now you can divide
this thing through it's a fraction after
all but we just don't have the tools yet
to do that so at the moment while I
haven't given you your hammer yet I'm
not going to give you nails that I
expect you to work it out you'll get
questions like this which you can just
do by hand more or less but later on
once we develop more tools just like now
you have calculus we give you harder
stuff later on I will give you a
question like this and I'll teach you
how to do it good does that make sense
okay in the exercises you've been given
in Cambridge they sneak in these oblique
asymptotes every now and then not
frequently but sometimes and you will
see it basically like this you can use
calculus to work out okay it's not just
approaching zero and you can use this
kind of trick here usually you can
actually just divide through the whole
thing and you will get something out the
other end sometimes just as a bonus so
we won't do it in detail but sometimes
just as a bonus you don't even get an
oblique asymptote for example if I gave
you something like this what happens
when I split it apart when I do this
trick here what am I going to get one of
the two fractions or two things yeah x
squared plus 1 over X now when you take
the limit of this thing when you take
the limit of this see how this guy's
going to go toward 0 as X gets huge so
what you get left behind is and not just
any admit it's this infinity right it's
a matter what this shape looks like it
looks like it is it looks like that so
in fact this is going to have I can tell
you exactly what this looks like this is
going to look like this mm-hmm
that's a weird shape right this is an
asymptote that's sort of curved I don't
even know if it's actually called an
asymptote when it's curved but it it
approaches it and gets closer closer
closer just like all the rest the
asymptotes that we've got
by the way that spot there is negative
one how did I do have a think look
carefully you can work that out
it's the x-intercept how do I usually
work out x-intercepts to work out
x-intercepts
I let y equal zero right so where is y
equals zero well it depends on this
numerator where this equals zero right
so you can see if I put negative one in
there the numerator becomes zero and if
that's not obvious enough then you can
do the sum of cubes what's the sum of
cubes x squared same opposite always
positive there you go you see x equals
negative one the whole thing collapses
so you get some weird interesting shapes
but at the moment all you have to do is
separate out you don't need any of this
weird polynomial division stuff and you
can work it out from there you could
shade regions and you would get this
shape you can work out where the
stationary point is as well how would
you do that yeah first riveted this guy
it's actually quite easy you can work it
out let's just work it out right now
that's why what's the first derivative
the first derivative will be 2x yeah
good so that's my first derivative so I
want this to be zero for stationary
points so stationary points means this
equals zero let's see here 2x equals one
on x squared I look okay hmm
X cubed equals R 1/2 okay so what's this
x-coordinate going to be I think it's
gonna be one on the cube root of two
isn't it whatever that happens to be I
have no idea what it is but bigger okay